Schlacht um die Macht Tag 3 und dann
diesem Tag dreht sich die Politik
komplett um ein selfie philippiatov dazu
bei uns im Studio dieses selfie ganz
genau es ist dieses Kult selfie muss man
jetzt schon sagen es ist zwar erst
gestern Abend aufgenommen aber ganz
Deutschland spricht jetzt schon darüber
auf jeden Fall das ganze politische
Berlin man sieht die ftp-spitze und die
Grünen Spitze von links nach rechts
FDP-Generalsekretär Volker Wissing Anna
Lena baerbock Christian Lindner und
Robert Habeck so starten also die
Sondierungsgespräche wir müssen noch gar
nicht erst mal über das politische
sprechen sondern das was da wirklich zu
sehen ist und man weiß halt nicht wo das
alles aufgenommen wurde man will nicht
mal verraten wer das selfie gemacht hat
aber die Körperhaltung von Volker
Wissing deutet darauf hin dass er das
selfie gemacht hat es sieht relativ
privat aus es könnte also eine
Privatwohnung sein jetzt müsste man
wissen wer von denen hat denn wirklich
eine Wohnung in Berlin Christian Lindner
hat auf jeden Fall eine und
interessantes ja auch was was darunter
steht vielleicht kann ich das einmal
vorlesen ist ein ganz lyrischer Text wie
man das aus der Politik eigentlich gar
nicht kennt auf der Suche nach einer
neuen Regierung loten wir
Gemeinsamkeiten und Brücken über
Trennendes aus und finden sogar welche
spannende Zeiten
persönlich Gedichte vorgetragen in der
Schule das war richtig ich habe mir Mühe
politische Lyrik absolut politische
Lyrik ich tippe dass es dass der Text
von Robert habe kommt ich glaube dass
Christian Lindner ihn auf jeden Fall mit
abgesegnet hat denn das Interessante ist
ja dass dieses selfie auf allen vier
Accounts Wissing bärbock Lindner Habeck
gleichzeitig mit dem gleichen Text
gepostet wurde ich glaube ich man kann
ausschließen dass Annalena baerbock das
geschrieben hat da war einfach die
plagiatsgefahr zu hoch nicht dass das
sie das einfach wieder abgeschrieben
hätte ich glaube das kommt von den
Machern dieses Bündnisses dieses
citrusbündnisses Habeck und Lindner das
ist also sagt Philipp piatov das
mächtigste selfie Deutschlands das
wichtigste selfie Deutschlands auf jeden
Fall heute und wir schauen uns einmal an
was daraus schon entstanden ist in
diesen wenigen Stunden warum Philipp
piathoff jetzt schon sagt das ist ein
absolutes Kult selfie
[Musik]
also die neue politische Familie da es
gibt ganz viele ja Kopien jetzt schon im
Netz von diesem selfie das geht auf
jeden Fall jetzt schon ins Haus der
Geschichte ein in unsere deutsche
Geschichte eines könnte der Anfang
tatsächlich sein einer großen
politischen Zusammenarbeit einer ganz
neuen politischen Zusammenarbeit absolut
auch das was wir gerade gesehen haben
dieses kleine lustige Video das geht
auch in der grünen Spitze und in der
FDP-Spitze schon viral ich habe das von
mehreren Personen heute früh gleich
zugeschickt bekommen als guten Morgen
Gruß und hier mit diesem selfie beginnt
die neue Erzählung die Erzählung der
neuen Koalition wir wissen zwar nicht
welches sein wird ob Jamaika oder Ampel
aber dieses zentrale Bündnis Grüne und
FDP das beginnt mit diesem selfie mit
diesem Vertrauens selfie man will ja
wirklich überhaupt nichts drüber
verraten das selfie soll für sich stehen
der Text soll für sich stehen man will
nichts sagen wer der wo es aufgenommen
wurde noch wann es aufgenommen wurde wer
das selfie gemacht hat komplettes
Stillschweigen dennoch sagt ja mehr
eigentlich als tausend Worte denn wenn
man das ist ja auch bewusst jetzt
diesmal die sozialen Medien genutzt alle
vier haben das gepostet alle vier haben
es verbreitet mit dem Wissen dass alle
es sehen werden absolut man will die
Kontrolle haben richtig man will
natürlich ein Zeichen dieser Einigkeit
aussenden die Einigkeit ist zwar noch
nicht wirklich da aber man muss sie
Einigkeit ja auch irgendwo herstellen
und zwar nicht nur untereinander sondern
man muss versuchen das auch der
Öffentlichkeit zu zeigen dass man
zusammen steht
dafür ist dieses Zelt wieder Philipp auf
dem Tisch gestellt haben wir hier mal
ganz viel Zitronen Limetten denn das was
wir auf diesem Foto sehen nennen wir
Citrus citruskoalition also ein ganz
wichtiges selfie für Deutschland warum
so wichtig so bedeutend ja es bestimmt
ja jetzt den Fortgang der
Koalitionsbildung dieses selfie ist der
Anfang der Erzählung wie wir regiert
werden und die beiden kleinen Parteien
Grüne und FDP die aber übrigens zusammen
größer sind als CDU oder SPD die wollen
jetzt ausloten mit wem sie regieren
wollen und erstmal ob sie überhaupt
selbst zusammenpassen deswegen passt
Citrus ja so richtig denn
es ist nicht so leicht der zusammen zu
kommen da habe ich da gibt es könnte
bitter werden es könnten Leute sauer
werden möglicherweise auch absolut
genauso ist es und deswegen dieses
selfie dass diese Einigkeit verströmen
soll alle vier Posten ist gleichzeitig
mit dem exakt gleichen Text sagen dass
sie Differenzen unterdrücken wollen so
geht es los wir sind jetzt offiziell der
Wahlkampf ist da mit diesem selfie
beendet wir sind jetzt in der
Koalitionsbildung was sind da die Themen
bei denen es besonders sauer besonders
bitter werden könnte jetzt wenn wir
dieses selfie sehen ist ja so viel
Einigkeit und Friede Freude Eierkuchen
so was man hier fast Caipirinha
zubereiten möchte aber eigentlich gibt
es hier so ein paar Knackpunkte da wird
es für die vier die da jetzt stehen auch
wirklich richtig schwierig absolut die
beiden Parteien haben total klare rote
Linien aufgezeigt bei der FDP ist es vor
allem das Steuer Thema auf keinen Fall
Steuererhöhungen und im Gegenteil
Steuersenkung und die Grünen fordern
eigentlich genau das Gegenteil die
Grünen haben aber ihrerseits wieder ein
Thema dass sie natürlich unter den
Nägeln brennt völlig klar Klimaschutz
und zwar nicht hier und da ein bisschen
mehr sondern das volle Programm dafür
kam ist man auch bereits Schulden
aufzunehmen der Staat will zeigen wohin
es geht und der Markt geht hinterher da
ist wirklich das kann blind da
eigentlich nicht akzeptieren deswegen
hilft so ein selfie das selfie geht
heute durch Deutschland das rast durch
die sozialen Netzwerke das selfie das
hier für diese
citruskoalition stehen soll stehen wird
das hat jetzt schon totalen Kultstatus
schauen wir mal rein was diese selfie
jetzt schon ausgelöst hat zum Beispiel
dieses Video nämlich
[Musik]
also muss man natürlich sagen nicht von
den vielen so zum Video gemacht mit wear
family aber das daraus entstanden das
ist ja natürlich genau die Botschaft
politisch lass uns noch mal genau bei
diesem selfie bleiben was wissen wir da
drüber also wo ist es aufgenommen wer
hat's gemacht wann ist es gemacht worden
und warum von allen Vieren genau
gleichzeitig mit demselben Text ja also
das Besondere an diesem selfie ist es
ist einerseits das Wichtigste das am
meisten diskutiertes selfie und
gleichzeitig das geheimnisvollste denn
die vier wollen nichts darüber verraten
die wollen nicht einmal sagen wer das
selfie aufgenommen hat aber was bedeutet
einiges darauf hin jetzt können wir noch
mal zeigen auch noch mal groß dass die
vier insta-posts von allen Vieren
wirklich zeitgleich gestern am ganz
späten Abend rausgegangen das hat jetzt
schon so
160.000 likes etwa im Netz und zwei
haben auch ein Filter draufgelegt das
finde ich auch immer interessant hier
muss ich noch mal hier Augen sind echt
aber davon nur noch mal ein bisschen
Filter noch mal schöner gemacht das
liegt ein bisschen wärmer nicht jeder
hat es einfach so gelassen ne hier Anna
Lena baerbock hat sagen ein bisschen
warme Farben noch mal drüber gelegt und
es deutet einiges darauf hin ist jetzt
auch kein Geheimnis also Christian
Lindner kann es eigentlich nicht gemacht
haben würde ich jetzt einmal ganz
geheimnisvoll sagen das ist ja
biologisch sehr sehr schwer umsetzbar
aus der Position ist deutet auf Volker
Wissing ist die Körperhaltung spricht
eigentlich für Volker Wissing
theoretisch könnte es auch Robert Habeck
gemacht haben dafür steht er ein kleines
bisschen zu locker da aber vielleicht
ist das ja Robe das große Talent von
Robert halbeck in jeder Situation selbst
beim selfie noch total entspannter zu
stehen aber ich glaube die
Körperspannung diese leichte Schräge
deutet auf Volker Wissingen aber selbst
das gehütet wie ein Staatsgeheimnis und
der Text der dazu gepostet wurde was
würdest du sagen woher stammt der der
ist ja auch bei allen Vieren genau
derselbe Text wonach klingt das genau
auf der Suche nach einer neuen Regierung
loten wir Gemeinsamkeiten und Brücken
über Trennendes aus und finden sogar
welche spannende Zeiten wirklich das
hört sich für mich nach Robert Habeck an
Robert Habeck ist ja Buchautor auch
Kinderbuchautor er ist Philosoph und
diese diese weiche Sprache das ist für
mich eigentlich ein klassischer Harbeck
aber er hat das garantiert nicht alleine
geschrieben und veröffentlicht und
entschieden sondern da muss Christian
Lindner auch ein Wort mitgeredet haben
also da schon der erste Kompromiss den
die wir zusammen machen konnten wir
nehmen dieses Foto und wir nehmen diesen
Text und das wo hast du irgendwelche
Hinweise wo das aufgenommen wurde das
sieht ja auf jeden Fall nach privater
Atmosphäre aus das ist jetzt nicht in
einem in Räumlichkeiten des Bundestags
ganz offenbar so sieht es nicht aus das
sieht nach einer offenbar ja Berliner
Wohnung aus wir wissen von allen Vieren
dass sich aktuell hier aufhalten also
das kann nirgendwo anders gewesen sein
was was spekulierst du wonach sieht das
aus bei wem das aufgenommen wurde also
es sieht nach einer Privatwohnung und es
sieht nach einer sehr gut bürgerlichen
Privatwohnung aus wenn man sich über
allen Vieren könnte das sein richtig
absolut die Frage ist natürlich ist ja
auch der der Lebensstil wohnt Robert
Habig so klar ist es auch ein gemachter
Mann mit einem tollen Gehalt seit vielen
Jahren aber die Wohnung von Robert
Habeck stellt man sich vielleicht ein
bisschen anders vor etwas bunter
Mitbringsel aus aller Welt viele Bilder
so stelle ich mir zumindest Robert
Habeck vor Christian Lindner gilt ja
eher so als der wohnt ein bisschen
gediegener ein bisschen schicker sehr
stilvoll daher es könnte seine Wohnung
sein gucken Kabeln
aus wenn er zu Hause bist oder da
spricht wieder so ein bisschen gegen
Christian Lindner weil wenn du zu Hause
ankommst machst du das als erstes so
hast Gäste oder vielleicht wird man bei
Christian hinter so förmlich zu Hause
begrüßt man weiß es ich kann mir
vorstellen dass Christian Lindner sein
Jackett aus hatte während man gesprochen
hat aber für das selfie muss das Jackett
an Christian Lindner und Jackett kann
man nicht voneinander trennen genauso
wie Robert Habeck natürlich keins trägt
klassisch in seinem schwarzen Hemd und
ja Annalena baerbock die da in der Mitte
dieses selfies steht steht aber halt
nicht mehr in der Mitte dieses
machtpokers Liebe citrusfreunde falls
Sie weitere Details haben zu diesem Foto
bitte melden Sie sich gerne auf Paul
ronsheimers Handy falls Sie mögen die
Nummer kennen Sie aber sie haben ja bis
hierhin Stillschweigen offenbar darüber
vereinbart das haben uns alle vier auch
bestätigt man will nicht dass das läuft
wie zwei 17 das ist in den Köpfen von
allen wir alle kennen doch diese Fotos
als da sondiert wurde wurde für eine
Dreierkonstellation beim vergangenen mal
und dann ging diese balkonbilder ja
durch Deutschland durch die Welt
in der parlamentarischen Gesellschaft
hier sehen wir Volker Bouffier hier
sehen wir vor allen Dingen Christian
Lindner in der Mitte neben Wolfgang
Kubicki und Kathrin Göring-Eckardt Horst
Seehofer natürlich dabei Alexander
Dobrindt diese Fotos da wurde noch mal
enige hocht auf dem Balkon diese Fotos
von Fotografen geschossen das gab
genauso ganz viele Fotos damals bei
Social Media daraus ist eins entstanden
vom Balkon und von innen immer wieder
inside Informationen Fotos damals nach
außen gedrungen aus der
parlamentarischen Gesellschaft gegenüber
vom Reichstagsgebäude damals auch
Christian Lindner halt fleißig
getwittert das können wir auch gleich
noch mal zeigen viele Teilnehmer damals
ständig Fotos rausgeschickt Robert
Habeck haben wir damals gesehen wir im
Hoodie geschlafen hat auf den Gängen der
parlamentarischen Gesellschaft und so
weiter das will man diesmal ganz gezielt
anders machen Philipp ganz genau diese
jamaika-verhandlung 2017 die wurden ja
dafür berühmt dass so viel raus
gesprochen wurde und zwar nicht einfach
nur um uns zu unterhalten nicht um
Kontakte mit Journalisten zu pflegen
sondern jeder wollte sein Spin hier
sehen wir den reiten das ist Robert
Habeck und hier der Post damals von
Christian Lindner also einer der Post
hier sind wir noch mal das ist ein
Robert Hoodie das ist ein ein Robert
Rudi so kann man ja sagen und auch diese
Fotos sind ja hochpolitisch ein
Politiker der sich die Nächte um die
Ohren legt der da schläft wo er arbeitet
und am nächsten Morgen weiterzumachen
also alle Teilnehmer dieser
jamaika-verhandlung 2017 haben diese
Verhandlungen genutzt um sich selbst
auch zu profilieren um ihre Geschichte
zu erzählen und die wissen jetzt glaube
ich das geht diesmal so nicht das wird
dann wieder scheitern deswegen macht man
um dieses Foto ja auch so ein Geheimnis
deswegen will man nicht verraten wo und
wann und von wem ist aufgenommen wurde
weil mit jedem es fängt ja immer mit dem
Detail an irgendjemand sagt ja es war
der Wissing
und wenn wir das dann berichten dann
fragen sich die anderen drei woher
wissen die das denn wenn der der Bild
irgendwas erzählt oder einem anderen
Medium wer weiß was der da noch
preisgibt deswegen dieser stillschweige
Pakt um dieses Vertrauen zumindest beim
ersten selfie komplett zu waren der
selfie packt das könnte die Erzählung
sein einer neuen citruskoalition
Patricia schauen wir noch einmal drauf
auf dieses selfie das uns das
Deutschland so bewegt heute hiermit hat
was zu tun mit den
Citrusfrüchten mit limetten und Zitronen
und das nicht etwa weil die vier da
irgendwie sauer reinschauen im Gegenteil
alle lächeln ganz entspannt in die
Kamera und Sie haben ja auch einen Grund
dazu denn sie sie sind nicht etwa die
Macher von Caipirinha sondern sie sind
die Königsmacher sie sind diejenigen die
entscheiden wie es in Deutschland
weitergeht und dieses Foto haben sie
gepostet alle mit dem gleichen Text
mancher hatten Filter draufgelegt damit
die Gesichtskonturen noch weicher sind
als eh schon und dieses darüber spricht
heute morgen Deutschland und wir
analysieren das jetzt diese politische
Bedeutung dieser zitruskoalition kann da
zusammen passen was eigentlich nicht
zusammengehört Philipp piathoff macht
eine Analyse der citrusteme und der
citrusperson
ja die citruskoalition im politischen
Schnellcheck wir haben mal fünf zentrale
Themen identifiziert und wollen einmal
drüber sprechen passen habe ich und
Lindner eigentlich zusammen fangen wir
beim Thema Bürgerrechte an beide
Parteien zählen sich als progressiv
beide Parteien haben eine starke
bürgerrechtsgeschichte hier sind sie
eigentlich relativ nah beieinander außer
bei einem kulturellen Thema die Grünen
sind die absolute gender Partei die FDP
haben sich kritisch beim Thema Gendern
positioniert also Bürgerrechte auf jeden
Fall das kulturelle etwas schwierig
dennoch relativ nah beieinander würde
ich sagen dann das Thema Digitalisierung
hier muss man sagen wir haben beide
eigentlich nur etwas zu gewinnen die
große Koalition hat ein absolutes
Brachland hinterlassen beide Parteien
stehen für Digitalisierung für Aufbruch
für dieses Start-up Mentalität also ich
glaube hier wird man sehr einer sehr
sehr nah zueinander Rücken
dann Klimaschutz hier wird es wieder
deutlich angespannter denn für beide
Parteien ist es dieses Thema zentral vor
allem natürlich für die Grünen die
getrieben werden von der Straße von
Fridays for future die jahrelang
Opposition gemacht haben
Oppositionspolitik mit der Forderung
nach immer mehr Klimaschutz und mit zwar
auch mit Verboten mit der immer teurer
Politik und gleichzeitig die Liberalen
die sagen der Markt muss entscheiden
deswegen hier könnte es knallen
hier stehen die beiden etwas weiter
auseinander dann kommen wir zum Thema
Steuern auch hier kann es knallen vor
allem weil die FDP schon gesagt hat wir
haben hier ganz klare rote Linien wir
wollen keine Steuererhöhung wir wollen
keine Vermögensabgabe sondern im
Gegenteil wir wollen die Menschen
entlasten die Grünen stehen wirklich
komplett anders die Grünen sind sowohl
für eine Vermögensabgabe als auch für
Steuererhöhung vor allem für besser
verdienende und da die FDP diese rote
Linie eingezogen hat muss hier
irgendjemand über seinen Schatten
springen auch hier absolutes
Konfliktpotenzial und dann das letzte
Thema Migration beide wollen aus
Deutschland eine moderne
zuwanderungsgesellschaft machen klar
passt kein Problem aber wenn es um die
kritischen Fragen geht um Abschiebung
auch um Abschiebung beispielsweise nach
Afghanistan da wird es wirklich kritisch
FTPs viel zu Wolfgang Kubicki hat bei
Bild sofort nach dem Fall von Kabul
gesagt Abschiebung nach Afghanistan
müsst möglich sein ist für die Grünen
vor allem für den linken Flügel eine
absolute Horrorvorstellung das heißt
beim Thema Migration Flüchtlinge
Abschiebung da kann es auch wieder
knallen da stehen die beiden Gewalt
auseinandergenommen
[Musik]